this morning a lawyer for five women who
accused Jeffrey Epstein of sex
trafficking says he wants to subpoena
Prince Andrew to testify and another
woman Virginia Roberts to Frey told our
partners at the BBC how she was
allegedly forced to have sex with the
Prince we go back to Buckingham Palace
where the Queen is preparing to meet
President Trump today in TS tyub is
there empty eyes what did you Frei say
yeah good morning Anthony we got another
damning interview on British television
this time Prince Andrew's accuser
speaking out against him I just been
abused by it a member of a royal family
and her first-ever British TV interview
Virginia Roberts to pray fought back
tears she alleges she was forced to have
sex with Prince Andrew three times while
still a teenager
it didn't last very long the whole
entire procedure it was disgusting
Roberts to phrase says she met Prince
Andrew at properties owned by convicted
sex offender Jeffrey Epstein and was
made to dance with Prince Andrew at a
London nightclub was horrible and this
guy was sweating all over me like his
sweat was like it was raining I have a
peculiar medical condition which is that
I don't sweat or I didn't sweat at the
time Prince Andrew says he has no
recollection of ever meeting Roberts to
pray despite being photographed with her
here now five more American women say
Prince Andrew witnessed the abuse at
Epstein's home and say their lawyer is
calling for Andrew to testify as far as
I was aware they were staff in an
auditory assent review last month he
says he didn't witness any suspicious
behavior at abstains homes buried in
thousands of US legal documents this
email seen by CBS News sent by the
Prince in January 2015 to his longtime
friend
Guylaine Maxwell where he asked let me
know when we can talk got some specific
questions to ask you about Virginia
Roberts raising even more questions
about what Prince Andrew knew cicerone
correspondent Roy anika the allegations
are coming thick and fast and there are
so many and
seems to be clearly not aware of
everything that's gone on so at the
moment it's just damage limitation as
best they can now Gail within the last
hour so CBS News have received this
statement from Buckingham Palace let me
read some of it to you it says it is
emphatically denied that the Duke of
York Prince Andrew had any form of
sexual contact or relationship with
Virginia Roberts any claim to the
contrary is false and without foundation
it also says that the Prince will
cooperate with investigators if asked
Gail well empty as he calls it false she
calls it a procedure someone's not
telling the truth there thank you very
much reporting from London